israël peut compter sur le soutien de
washington pour continuer l'installation
de colonies dans les territoires
palestiniens
c'est l'avis de riccardo bocco
spécialiste du moyen-orient à l'institut
des hautes études internationales et du
développement à la position aujourd'hui
il y en ait conforté par l'appui
américain à novembre 2019 le secrétaire
d'état michael bay avait déclaré après
avoir reconnu comme légal l'annexion du
golan par l'état israélien a déclaré que
du point de vue américain
les colonies n'étaient pas illégales ce
qui était équivalent à 1 a donné carte
blanche au gouvernement netanyahou de
poursuivre la colonisation
ces colonisations aujourd'hui
concrètement qu'est ce que cela signifie
signifie environ 600 mille colons dans
la cisjordanie et plus de 200 mines
autour de jérusalem et dans jérusalem
est
donc la stratégie et une stratégie qui
vise à priver non seulement de leurs
doigts de base les citoyennes
palestiniens mais de les pousser à
quitter à vider les lieux qu'ils
habitent afin que à moyen terme à long
terme et à israël hier puisse le peuple
est avec des colons juifs et donc
aboutir son projet du eretz israël le
grand israël qui aura également inclus
la cisjordanie